what we've heard today from dominic  cummings is a shocking  testimony revealing chaos  lack of grip incompetence an abdication  of leadership  at the very top of government when we  were facing the biggest emergency  since the second world war he's made  some very  grave allegations against matt hancock  which on the face of it  look well founded matt hancock must come  to the house of commons  tomorrow and explain what he did to  protect care homes because so many  people did die  in care homes what he did to get the ppe  to the front line  was what he did on testing and tracing  because it didn't work still doesn't  work  to this day these are serious  allegations which  matt hancock now needs to give us an  explanation explanation for  if the public is to maintain confidence  in him